sort the drawings according to the
equation that correctly describes the
relationship between the vectors drawn
an equation may have any number of cards
and cards with no corresponding equation
should be left on sorted so let's see
what they're talking about here so right
over here they have depicted let's see
they're adding vector a to vector B and
we see that because vector B's tail is
at the head of vector a so they're
adding vector a to vector B and if you
connect the tail of vector a to the head
of vector B you get vector C so they're
really showing that vector A plus vector
B is equal to vector C so let's see if
we can find that so a is showing that
vectors a plus B vector A plus vector B
is equal to vector C now let's look at
the second choice this choice right over
here showing that vector B plus vector C
is equal to vector a so B plus C is
equal to a C that is this choice right
over here so diagram or graph B is
showing us that vector B plus vector C
is equal to vector a now let's look at
this choice right over here this is
showing us that B plus a is equal to C
or it doesn't matter which way you order
them but or it could be well the way the
way they've set it up this is B plus a
is equal to C so that is that is not one
of the choices but you could you could
whether you're doing a plus B or B plus
a it's going to be the same thing so I'm
going to throw it into this category
right over here this is the same thing
as a plus B instead of putting the tail
of B at the head of a they just put the
tail of a at the head of B but it
doesn't matter what order you are you
are adding those two vectors you're
still going to get the same vector C and
then finally this right over here this
is C plus a is equal to B so let's see
so this is C plus a or a plus C is equal
to B doesn't matter if we do vector A
plus vector C or vector C plus vector a
so let's just make sure that we've got
all of these right and we have